retour en france avec une série de
mesures annoncées par le gouvernement
pour lutter contre le racisme au travail
martine aubry réunit sept aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
il faut dire que d'après le dernier
rapport du haut conseil à l'intégration
la discrimination est un fait
indiscutable les syndicats sont
d'ailleurs désormais autorisés à saisir
la justice pour aider les plaignants
martinek marque savinaud ici avec sa
fille sylvie quoi mais elle est
française d'origine ivoirienne
elle a fait toute sa scolarité en france
jusqu'au bac professionnel ensuite elle
enchaîné les petits boulots et les
vexations par exemple à la restauration
avant que le nouveau responsable
n'arrive
j'étais à la caisse dès qu'il est arrivé
il m'a mis à la page
j'étais aussi le demande dans un grand
magasin pour être caissière en m'a dit
n'en comprenaient pas de noirs à la
caisse mais quand elle avait notre place
pour moi c'était le ménage mahmoud est
lui aussi français
malgré son bts ils ne trouvent pas de
travail alors sur ses cv il a changé son
prénom est devenu marc diouane et les
réponses sont ravivées la discrimination
raciale est totalement illégal mais en
france la justice est rarement saisie il
n'y en a peur générale pour une raison
simple c'est qu'il est très difficile de
faire la preuve des faits qui sont
reprochés
pourquoi parce que essentiellement parce
que les personnes qui peuvent pourraient
témoigner ce sont les collègues de
travail et qui ont peur pour leur emploi
pour lutter contre le racisme au travail
et martine aubry a réuni aujourd'hui
tous les partenaires sociaux parmi les
mesures envisagées un programme de
sensibilisation de tous les
professionnels
d'abord les agents publics il faut par
exemple que les agents de l'anpe sache
refusé une offre d'emploi lorsqu'on leur
dit qu'elle doit être réservé à telle
personne ou à telle couleur
également saisir la justice le progrès
aujourd'hui sur ce texte c'est de
permettre aux gens qui sont victimes de
ces faits de discrimination de savoir
qu'ils ont à leur disposition les
organisations syndicales pour la prise
en charge de leurs problèmes
autre mesure le pouvoir des inspecteurs
du travail va être renforcée ce
dispositif devrait être mise en place
l'an prochain